all right may you had a pretty decent
run of it there brought us some pretty
sweet new games but it's over okay you
gotta go June's here and it looks pissed
oh hey tune didn't see you there why
don't you come on in and tell us all
about those free games you brought for
Xbox Live Gold members two games for the
Xbox one and three for the Xbox 360 make
five good reasons why June is my new
favorite month now free halo for Xbox
one may sound like the title of a
phishing email but 343 industries
isometric blast em up halo Spartan
assault is totally free for your Xbox
one this month many of the iconic
weapons and vehicles from the Halo verse
are here in adorable dollhouse miniature
form as you take on the Cubbies solo or
team up an online co-op to battle the
bar faced flood look still yucky after
all these years the other Xbox one
freebie is maxed the curse of
brotherhood in which you must wart your
older brothers attempts to hog the Sega
Genesis and eat all the good colored
skittles I kid I kid
in this puzzly platformer you actually
labyrinth your annoying little brother
to a far-off land and now you gotta go
save them gorgeous visuals and a few
interesting puzzles make this one
appealing but there's one caveat to keep
in mind both halo Spartan assault and
Max the curse of Brotherhood are only
going to be available for part of June
but they haven't announced which part
yet so you're just gonna have to keep an
eye on gamespot news to figure out when
these freebies will be up for grabs on
over to the Xbox 360 let's see what we
got here holy but Dark Souls for free
Dark Souls the challenging thrilling
frightening fantastic Dark Souls perhaps
the greatest role-playing adventure of
this or any generation that Dark Souls
for free is this really true holy Butz
it's really true Wow
hey um get this game for free but you
only can grab it from June 1st to June
15
mahan darksouls poof that's awesome
all right let's move on to see what poor
game is gonna look like chopped liver
next to Dark Souls it's Charlie murderer
actually not available until June 16th
through June 30th the second half of the
month this boozy punk brawler has a
brash style that will certainly shake
things up around the old living room as
you alternately brawl and rock your way
through hordes of zombies and demons and
other unpleasantries that want to kill
you grab some band mates get tatted up
and Charlie yourself some murders I
don't know why that wasn't the tagline
the third and final Xbox 360 game you
can download for the low low cost of
free if you're a gold member in June is
Super Street Fighter for arcade edition
hadoukens yoga flames
whatever this crazy oily dude calls this
move get your punchy kicky pile-driving
fun as you take on local friends or
online foes with a roster of 39
characters in this finely tuned entry in
one of gaming's most venerable
franchises like Charlie murder this
one's only free from June 16th to June
30th and there you have it all the big
gaming news you're gonna need for June
unless you know this little III shindig
turns out to be anything this year we'll
see in the meantime just enjoy your free
games